her physical disability from spina
bifida left her without much movement or
feeling in her legs
but she was an accomplished wheelchair
user who was competitive in National
Wheelchair Sports
she went to a mainstream School
she had a learning assistant to help her
with things in school she simply could
not do herself
but she would not allow people
so much as to push her wheelchair or
open a door for her
everything she could do for herself she
did
but she died just after her 16th
birthday
you Sarah Lloyd Jones her mother
and you Alan tipford her father
caused her death
by Shocking and prolonged neglect over
lockdown
which you by your guilty please Sarah
Lloyd Jones
and a jury by a unanimous verdict Alan
titford have proved to be gross
negligence manslaughter on your part
for those crimes I now pass sentence
I will Briefly summarize the facts of
the case particularly relevant to
sentence
my summing up to the jury in the case
that Alan tickford sent out the evidence
more fully
much of it applicable to both of you
and the crown has opened the case
Katie tipford was born with
hydrocephalus and spina bifida in 2004.
she was born with normal weight
but by the time she was three her weight
had risen to the heaviest
99.6th centile of relevant weight on a
scale of 1 to 100.
at four years old she started mainstream
primary school and at six she was
already good at physical activities and
games in her wheelchair
at 11 or so she went on to mainstream
Secondary School
concerns about her weight led to a
concerted effort by professionals to
work with the family to improve her diet
and stabilize her weight
Sarah Lloyd Jones did not attend these
appointments after the first one but
Alan tipford attended instead
for two years from 2011 there was
success for which the family was given
credit
but in 2013 when she was 9 or 10 a
number of years before Kaylee's death
the stabilization of her weight came to
an end and weight gain was an issue
until she died
there was a history of missed
appointments
some of these ended the provision of
relevant Services because professionals
took the view that there was no point in
scheduling appointments which were not
being attended
both defendants were aware that help was
available from a variety of agencies
but they did not make full use of that
help as time went on
by the end they were not accessing or
accepting any significant help at all
for Kane
the whole burden of looking after her
therefore fell on them but this was not
for reasons beyond their control
it was part of their gross negligence
towards the well-being of their daughter
I do not accept that Alan tickford
thought that Sarah Lloyd Jones was
looking after Kaylee well enough on her
own
it was obvious that she was failing
he did not need to look at her legs to
see that
he would go into Kaylee's room from time
to time as he did on her birthday and
when he got back from work on other days
but he ignored the smell and the dirt
and the Flies and the chaos and the
evidence of his own eyes and nose
that she was not getting the cash she
needed
there are texts in which Sarah Lloyd
Jones begged for his help
he didn't give any help
his long hours at work are not an excuse
he liked working he did not like helping
he was as he freely accepted too lazy to
help
he expressed some Scruples about getting
involved in the personal care of a
daughter who had reached puberty but his
neglect was total
and he could and should have done more
to help and ask others for help instead
when he was not at work he sat in his
bedroom upstairs watching television
equally I do not accept that Sarah Lloyd
Jones can throw the blame onto her
husband
it was too much for her to do on her own
that I do accept
but it was her duty to ask for help and
to accept it from the agencies which
over the years she sometimes ignored or
turned away
when she had a telephone appointment
with Birmingham Children's Hospital in
May 2020 she did not say that help was
needed for Kaylee
she was positively offered help in
August 2020 by contact from a Young
Person's lymphedema specialist
and later contact from a young people
specialist
and later contact from the Youth
Intervention service
she did not take up any of these offers
when Kaylee's non-attendance at school
was queried after schools reopened in
September 2020
she made various excuses for not sending
Kaylee back without disclosing what was
really happening
I find it impossible to say that one
parent was more to blame than the other
they were both equally responsible
and they were both equally culpable
Kaylee was found dead in bed on the
morning of the 10th of October 2020
however Sarah Lloyd Jones basis of plea
and the facts proved to the criminal
standard at Alan tidford's trial
show that their failure to take
reasonable care for Kaylee's Health and
Welfare needs took place over a period
between the start of lockdown on the
23rd of March 2020 when Kaylee stopped
going to school
and her death
a period of over six months
this was not a lapse on the part of the
defendants
it was a long and sustained period of
criminal negligence
I say that having Taken full account of
the better care given to Kaylee before
lockdown
the particulars of criminal negligence
again accepted in the basis of plea and
proven at trial included the increase in
Kaylee's weight which rose from 16 Stone
12 pounds 107 kilograms when she was
last weighed alive in March 2018 at the
age of 13.
to her post-mortem weight of 22 stone 13
pounds
146 kilograms on the 11th of October
2020 which was shortly after her 16th
birthday on the 27th of September
her body mass index was 70.
there was no attempt to control her diet
she could only eat what she was given
which by the end was the same fattening
takeaways that everyone else was eating
it was perfectly obvious from her
physical appearance and would have been
to both defendants that Kaylee was
morbidly and dangerously obese not only
did her parents not watch her diet as
they had been taught to do they failed
to get her a wheelchair to replace the
one she had grown out of
this left her completely bedridden and
her lack of ability to move herself
caused still greater increase in weight
her immobility also removed her ability
to extricate herself from the general
squalor into which the defendants sank
her
she was in a specially adapted room in a
specially adapted house with her own
disabled toilet
but she had long since been unable to
toilet herself
by the time of her death she was lying
in her own filth
surrounded by flies which bothered her
and maggots which fed on her
her flesh was disfigured by ulcers which
left her skin open down to the fat and
in one place down to the bone
the stench created as her body rotted
away alive and from the excrement left
to dry unattended around and on her body
and in the room
made paramedic and police officers of
long experience wretch and feel
physically sick when they attended on
the body
the ulsters on Kaylee's body caused by
pressure sores lack of hygiene lack of
movement and lack of Professional Care
were the worst the expert had ever seen
I'm not going to go through the details
of the evidence it has been fully opened
by the crown today and I heard the
evidence of trial
this was a horrifying case a case of
sustained neglect leading to the death
of a completely dependent
bedridden vulnerable
disabled child at the hands of her own
parents
and it is not only the death
I have no doubt
that the suffering
and degradation she experienced before
she died
was prolonged and significant
while it is true
that she had no feeling in her lower
limbs
where most of the ulcers were she could
see and smell her own filth
she and her sister called for help in
text messages
what was happening was obvious to anyone
who went into the room and it would have
been obvious to her
Kaylee could see the Flies and the
maggots she complained about the Flies
she could see the bottles of urine from
her catheter left unempted and
uncollected from the floor
she could see that her wheelchair Was
Out Of Reach she would know it was now
too small for her anyway
she could see dirty bedding and the mess
in the room and she knew she had not
been properly washed for a long time
even if she could not see her own
blackened armpits and had limited or no
feeling in parts of her visibly crusty
and ulcerated skin
for a girl of her age
and independent spirit
this was a particularly terrible state
to find herself in
in her last hours the night before
Kaylee's body was found cold and dead
her father heard her screaming
she had already turned her mobile phone
off for the last time
her father's reaction to the screaming
was to text her telling her to stop
twice
he did not go and see what the matter
was or get whatever help she needed
she was left to die alone
from the indictment the key to the
indictment the basis of plea the
evidence and the jury verdict the
following facts are clear both
defendants owed Kaylee a duty of care as
parents with the care of their disabled
child they breached that Duty by failing
to take reasonable care for her Health
and Welfare needs they failed to take
reasonable steps to prevent Kaylee from
becoming morbidly obese to ensure that
Kaylee did not stay immobile for periods
of time which were bad for her health
and well-being to ensure she had a safe
and hygienic environment to live in to
ensure that Kaylee maintained a hygienic
physical state or to ensure that her
physical health needs were met and that
medical assistance was sought when
needed
it was reasonably foreseeable at the
time that this gave rise to a serious
and obvious risk of death and it was a
significant cause of Kaylee's death it
was gross negligence
so gross as to be a crime
have the benefit of written and oral
submissions from Council pre-sentence
reports for both defendants and a report
on Sarah Lloyd Jones from Dr Christine
tizard she has a doctorate in Psychology
and is a chartered consultant
psychologist there is an addendum
pre-sentence report responsive to Dr
tizard
I will apply the gross negligence
manslaughter guidelines
present in this case is the category B
factor of both defendants continuing
their negligent conduct in the face of
the obvious suffering caused to Kaylee
by that conduct
I do not accept that this was a case of
lapse in an otherwise satisfactory
standard of care
the standard of care had been inadequate
for a long time before death
it was criminal through the whole period
of lockdown
there was plenty of time to get help for
Kaylee and to put things right for her
in all of that time things went from bad
to worse
I do not accept that either parents can
claim a lesser or subordinate role in
the responsibility to Kaylee or in their
gross negligence in discharging that
responsibility and causing her death
they are both equally responsible
I do not accept that any blame that may
have attached to outside agencies for
not being more proactive
can be used to reduce the defendant's
primary responsibility as parents to
reach out for the help which they knew
from experience was available
help was there for the taking it was
there for the asking it had been given
before
both defendants completely neglected to
get the help that Kaylee needed and
sometimes it was ignored when it was
offered
this can be seen at earlier periods from
the evidence and in the chronologies
from medical and other records
the failure to get any help at all even
from Kaylee's GP was particularly
significant in The crucial lockdown
months leading to Kaylee's death
I have considered whether either
defendant's responsibility was
substantially reduced by mental disorder
learning disability or lack of maturity
and I've also considered the separate
guideline on sentencing offenders with
mental disorders
putting with Sarah Lloyd Jones the
tizzard report dated the 7th of November
2022 is based on a proof of evidence and
council's advice a detailed prosecution
case summary which from the date must
have been the one uploaded on the 22nd
of March 2022
and a single Zoom interview on the 1st
of November 2022
it does not take account of the later
pre-sentence report or the evidence
actually given at trial or I am told any
medical records
it was prepared over two years after
Kaylee's death
and it is in my judgment not a reliable
guide to her mental state at the time of
the offending
although I accept it as evidence of her
mental state at the time of the zoom
interview
she told Dr tizard that she was
depressed but she said she was not
depressed and did not suffer from any
mental health issues before Kaylee's
death
it is in that context that I read her
basis of plea which says that lockdown
impacted on her Mental Health
that was the case for many people
without amounting to a significant
mental disorder
Dr tizard herself noted that what she
was being told was in large areas
muddled or confused and in some cases
inconsistent with other evidence for
example she said that Kaylee did not
like school but the evidence that
Charles showed that she did like it
she said her husband was not violent
towards her but the police said she had
called them several times when he had
been aggressive
although I have given careful
consideration to Dr tizard's report
including its current diagnosis of major
depression I have also weighed the
evidence as a whole and I am satisfied
that Sarah Lloyd Jones was fully aware
and fully responsible for what was
happening when Kaylee was alive she had
no mental disorder learning disability
or lack of maturity which substantially
reduces her responsibility
her intelligence was in an average range
albeit low average
turning to Alan titford it is clear from
the pre-sentence report that he was
diagnosed with depression about 10 years
ago and that in the past he has been
voluntarily admitted to Psychiatric
Hospital sometimes because of depression
and sometimes because of drug-induced
psychosis
however no episodes of this nature are
alleged in recent times
nor did he in evidence to the jury blame
his conduct on mental health issues he
was not on any medication and says he
did not want any support from the
community mental health Team
having heard him give evidence I see no
reason to disbelieve his
self-description as simply lazy
I do not adopt the report writer's
alternative theory that this is likely
to be owing to his experience of
depression and general pattern of
avoidance coping
being lazy meant not doing unpleasant
work that he didn't want to do
it is not inconsistent with enjoying the
work of a removals man
he accepted in evidence that he could
have done more for Kaylee
in his case also I find that he had no
mental disorder learning disability or
lack of maturity which substantially
reduces his responsibility
this means that there are in my judgment
no category D factors in this case
assessing all the relevant factors and
considering the case as a whole I'm
confident in placing the offending of
both defendants in category B with a
guideline starting point of eight years
custody in a custody range of 8 to 12
years custody
I consider the heightened rather than
extreme nature of the category B factor
in this case of prolonged negligence in
the face of obvious suffering to be
treated more fairly as an aggravating
Factor than as sufficient in the absence
of any of the other category B factors
on its own in this case to raise the
case into category a
the conditions in which Kaylee was left
to die
were fairly described by the crown as
unfit for any animal
however there was no deliberate cruelty
there is no evidence of dislike
or of targeting
it is a case of criminal neglect
and gross negligence
it is a particularly serious case of its
kind and that does require some upward
movement from the guideline starting
point
there are no other aggravating factors
which I've not already taken into
account when deciding the category of
culpability and I must not double count
I now turn to mitigating factors
Sarah Lloyd Jones has no previous
convictions and Alan titford has no
recent or relevant previous convictions
that is litigation
I accept the personal mitigation put
forward on behalf of both defendants
I accept that both parents have been
grieved by the loss of their daughter
and that Sarah Lloyd Jones Is Now
correctly diagnosed as suffering from a
major depressive disorder I accept that
she struggled with the care of Kaylee
Alan titford also has personal
mitigation to which I have given weight
I accept that lockdown created unusual
circumstances although both defendants
were going out to work after March 2020
neither defendant was cut off from the
outside world
none of the other guideline factors
reducing seriousness or reflecting
personal litigation applies
it is clear to me that what the
defendants could not do
and the stress and pressure of looking
after a number of children including
Kaylee with her special needs was within
their power to deal with by calling for
appropriate help
which they did not do
their failures were not for reasons
beyond their control
they never asked for help they did not
get
they did not ask for help at all
it was made easy for them
to ask for help
I do not accept that either defendant
has shown remorse that should count as
significant mitigation Alan titford
pleaded not guilty and even to the
author of the presentence report blamed
his partner and even his daughter
Sarah Lloyd Jones pleaded guilty and
will get credit for that
but Dr tizan's report and the
pre-sentence report show that she still
continues to try and shift blame
elsewhere and to minimize her own
responsibility
balancing the aggravating and mitigating
factors I feel able to reduce the
starting point to seven years six months
for both defendants before credit for
plea
I make no finding of dangerousness in
this case and there is no need for an
extended license period for the
protection of the public
Sarah Lloyd Jones is entitled to credit
for her guilty plea she entered a not
guilty plea at The Plea and trial
preparation hearing on the 1st of July
the case was listed for trial on the
16th of January 2023
she entered a guilty plea at a pre-trial
hearing on the 12th of December 2022.
this is not a case in which she needed
council's advice or the report of Dr
tizard to inform her decision to plead
guilty
following the sentencing guideline I
assess the appropriate credit to be 20
percent
that reduces the sentence in her case
from seven years six months to six years
Alan titford did not plead guilty and
gets no credit
I'm not asked to make any ancillary
orders and I do not think any are
necessary
both defendants have been on bail
without electronic monitoring and so
there is no credit for time served
before a trial
each defendant must pay the statutory
surcharge of 190 pounds or such other
correct figure as may be substituted
administratively
Alan titford stand up
for the gross negligence manslaughter of
Kaylee titford I sentence you to seven
years six months imprisonment you will
serve two-thirds of the sentence namely
five years in custody before you are
released on license when you are
released you will be on license until
the end of this sentence
you must comply with the terms of the
license and commit no further offense or
else you will be liable to serve a
further period in custody
you may go down
stand up Sarah Lloyd James
for the gross negligence manslaughter of
Kaylee tipford having regard to your
guilty plea I sentence you to six years
imprisonment you will serve two-thirds
of the sentence namely four years in
custody before you are released on
license when you are released you will
be on license until the end of your
sentence you must comply with the terms
of the license and commit no further
offense or else you'll be liable to
serve a further period in custody
you may go down